looking to build a flexible smart and
secure data analytics platform give me
one minute and i'll show you how
dataplex can help
enterprises have distributed data across
data lakes data warehouses and data
marts they service a diverse set of
users who want data available across
various tools for analytics and machine
learning
this is extremely difficult to manage as
it needs to build and manage the
connections between all these analytics
tools replicate security governance and
metadata management and balance multiple
pricing models
dataplex is an intelligent data fabric
that can help it unifies your
distributed data to help automate data
management and power your analytics at
scale
what does this mean to you
it enables standardization and
unification of metadata security
policies governance and data
classification for consistent controls
across storage devices
data intelligence using google's
best-in-class aiml capabilities is
built-in to automate data discovery
meta-data harvesting lifecycle
management and data quality
this automatically makes data securely
accessible for analytics and data
science via a variety of google cloud
native and open source tools no matter
where the data lives
dataplex offers you a single pane of
glass to organize curate secure and
analyze your data while giving you the
flexibility to store data where you see
fit and use the best analytics tools for
the job with dataplex you no longer have
to build or manage the fabric that holds
your data analytics platform together we
have you covered so next time you're
looking to take your analytics to planet
scale take a minute to look at dataplex
to learn more check out
cloud.google.com
dataplex
you